hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the great pleasure of sitting today
with gert vandenbusch garrett
vandenbusch
is a doctor of veterinary medicine who
has specialist expertise
in virology and vaccinology
he has worked in industry in the
construction of vaccines he has also
worked
in the non-profit sector in bringing
immunity to larger numbers of people
uh welcome garrett thanks everybody for
having me
so you have become well known
in certain circles and controversial of
late because you have
deployed an argument that suggests that
the current campaign
to vaccinate large numbers of people in
the midst of the covet 19 pandemic
may be ill-advised and i have seen
you have been accused widely of being an
anti-vaxxer which is
uh completely preposterous in light of
the career
that you have uh you have participated
in
um do you want to say any words up front
about where you're
coming from uh in deploying your warning
and then we can get into some of the
biology that
will be relevant to the argument that
you're making
well brett what i could say is that for
me the alarming point
came when i realized or we
realized as a community that all of a
sudden this was back in november last
year
a number of highly infectious variants
were popping up
almost simultaneously that was one thing
and the second thing was when um
vaccination started that there were some
reports
that were reporting indeed about uh
you know people being vaccinated and
still shedding virus
so the combination of these things the
presence
even before mass vaccination started of
highly infectious strains that were
already present
and then this combined with the fact
that
the vaccines as most vaccines do not
prevent against infection
and enable people who are vaccinated to
shed the virus and basically to spread
it
so this was the for me the alarming
point
interesting so from my perspective one
of these things
uh it seems to me is obvious
that we would see it it's essentially no
matter where
this virus came from we would expect in
light of the fact
of effectively a point source we would
expect a large number of variants to
emerge
on the basis that this virus is new to
people
and it is now experiencing uh
a effectively a very large canvas on
which to learn
new tricks so i find
nothing surprising about the idea that
new variants are are popping up we
should have expected that
the other point that you make is not so
obvious from my perspective that people
who are vaccinated
may still be shedding virus in other
words they do not have
immunity sufficient to ward off the
infection and prevent them
from infecting others is that is that
what you're saying
yeah but this is this is pretty normal
for conventional vaccines
there is uh there are only a few very
few vaccines and you would rather
need to look into life vaccines life
attenuated vaccines
most of our modern vaccines prevent
against disease
and to some extent they diminish of
course the the spread of the infection
they diminish the viral load to some
extent
really substantially but they do not
completely prevent infection
um yeah so this then sets up
uh a hazard in the form of a trade-off
that the vaccines are very good at
preventing people from
becoming sick but by being
narrowly focused and not preventing the
shedding of a virus they open
an evolutionary pathway for
the virus to learn new tricks because
that is to say somebody
who has substantial immunity but not
complete immunity
to the virus will will
tend to shed new variants that have
making made use of that
higher bar or that have cleared the
higher bar
well if the variants are present already
which was the case before the mass
vaccination
really got got rolled out the mass
vaccination campaigns
and of course the we are talking about
the spike protein i think everybody by
know
knows more or less about the spike
protein as we know the version
of the spike protein in the vaccines is
not the same
as on the variance so there there is
some heterologous situation
and therefore it's also logical that
when you are vaccinated but you are
exposed to a variant that has a
different version of the s-protein
that the s-protein may not be completely
recognized by the vaccinal antibodies
and therefore not completely
completely neutralized for example so
that is pretty logical
it only becomes a problem i guess if you
do this at a very
large scale and that is my argument the
mass vaccination
in the midst of a massive infectious
pressure which is
the case during a pandemic of course all
right so
here's my suggestion in order for people
to understand
what is i think a fairly subtle
distinction deploying
a vaccine like one of the ones that we
currently have
narrowly targeted at the spike protein
in advance of a pandemic
might work very well and in the midst of
a pandemic might have exactly the
opposite
impact the the reason for that is
clear enough to me but i think it will
be obscure to almost everyone so let's
talk a little bit about
the immune system and how it functions
so that people can understand the
context
of your argument so i should say
my background i did not i have no degree
in either virology or vaccine
science but i did study this many years
ago
in the context of basically i took a
course in the medical school that i was
interested
in in immunobiology which is basically
the biology of the immune system that
underlies
both the natural immunity that we have
and the immunity that we create
with um with vaccines
so we essentially have we can
dichotomize the systems that create
immunity
in a number of different ways one of
them is that we have something called
innate immunity these are the ability to
recognize pathogens or other
disease-causing patterns
without needing to have any exposure and
then we have what's called acquired
immunity
acquired immunity is for example people
all will have had the experience
of getting sick with something a cold or
a flu
and then uh a couple of weeks later they
will find themselves
recovered and what has happened is that
the immune system
has learned the electromagnetic
signature
on the surface of the um
the either the viruses or the
cells that have been infected these are
called antigens
and having learned that specific pattern
it is then
very good at finding cells that have
been infected and
destroying them or triggering them to
self-destruct
and once you have that then a set of
memory cells are created
so that if you ever encounter the same
pathogen again creating the same
antigens
the immune system is so quick to
recognize it that we very frequently
don't even realize that we've been
invaded
right so you don't tend to get the same
cold twice
or chickenpox for example
all right so what i want you to do
i i'm going to sort of stand halfway
between
what you understand and what my audience
is likely to understand
and just try to paint with a broad brush
some
detail about the systems here so that
people can follow
so the acquired immunity
is carried in two kinds of cells
broadly speaking we've got b cells which
make antibodies
people who have heard the term
antibodies antibody is basically a
y shaped protein and that y shaped
protein
floats freely and it sticks to things
based on
the electromagnetic the pattern of
electromagnetic
magnetic charge on the the pads on the
tips
um and so those antibodies float around
and they attach themselves to
bacteria or to virally infected cells
and uh that has a number of consequences
and then the t
cells uh function very much like b
cells except that instead of creating
free-floating
antibody the what look like antibodies
remain on the surface of the t
cells and they function as receptors so
the t cells move around
and when they encounter something that
their receptors stick to an antigen for
which they're well matched
those t cells become triggered to do
something how am i doing so far
yeah yeah that's uh that's okay so there
is uh
just the t cells that then then can
immediately
destroy the infected cell because as you
were pointing out they recognize
an antigen of the pathogen on the
surface of that cell
but there are also the t cells that will
provide help
to the b cells in order to build that
memory
if there is no t help there will no be
no b-cell memory
so there is two types of t-cells that
are important to helper cells
to enhance the b-cell response and
the cytotoxic t-cells that have the
capability
to immediately destroy a cell an
infected cell provided they recognize
the antigen on the surface of that cell
great all right so help me remember that
we want to come back to that so people
understand what it means
what i want to do is talk about the way
in which acquired immunity
is acquired in the first place so that
we can then understand what these memory
cells
are so acquired immunity i must say
is one of the most fascinating
evolutionary processes
i've ever heard of the first time i
learned of this
my jaw was on the floor it was so
interesting that such a system
had evolved and existed and functioned
without our awareness
24 hours a day every day of your life
so the system functions more or less in
this way
you have a an array of cells
that produce antibodies which
have an ability sort of a general
ability to react to
any large organic molecule any
configuration of charges that an antigen
might have
is contained in the system there are
multiple cells in the system that will
react to it somewhat
so you have billions billions is that
the right order of magnitude maybe it's
tens of billions
of well it's a huge amount anyway it's a
very large number of these cells
existing in your body that have a very
wide range of
patterns of antigen that they can react
to and you have these things
before you're born now the system will
react
really in principle to any sizable
organic molecule but it's
very important that it not react to
molecules that you yourself make
and so what happens is the system during
a critical period in development
eliminates all of those cells that are
triggered
by your own molecules
and the fact of being a mammal plays
into this very interestingly because
there's a period
before you've been exposed to the world
where the only molecules you're
encountering are your own
so the system wakes up to all of the
members of the this class of cells that
react
in utero and it eliminates them and what
that does is it creates a system that
once you've been
born and you're out in the world and you
encounter molecules that
aren't yours the system reacts but when
it encounters molecules that you're
making it doesn't so it creates a
self-non-self-recognition system
that's what we call tolerance to the
self-antigens
right we become taller and if you
weren't tolerant you'd have an
autoimmune disorder your immune system
would be attacking your own cells and
maybe we'll talk a little bit about what
that might uh represent later on but
the what i want to get people to
understand is that the system
in its initial state just simply reacts
to anything that isn't you
right and what isn't you might be a
pathogen or it might not
right you could breathe in some pollen
pollen isn't
actually utilizing your cells to do
anything it's just an organic
molecule that you've inhaled and your
system might react to it as if it was
dangerous that would be an allergy
but when you are invaded by let's say a
bacterium
or a virus you are suddenly creating
molecules that your system has never
seen and your system begins to react but
at first
it reacts very weakly because it doesn't
have a very
good program for recognizing this
specific new invader it has a very
general program that just recognizes
anything it does it hasn't seen before
right
but this is the really amazing part
the cells that react a little bit to
this new pathogenic
pattern those cells create a bunch of
offspring cells that are not identical
to each other
and those cells among the offspring
cells that react
even more strongly to the pathogen are
then triggered to produce
more offspring cells and so what this
does is it uses
quite literally evolution to generate
a recognition of this new pathogen that
your body has never seen but it learns
over the course of hours days
and weeks to recognize this new pattern
and it becomes very very good at it
right at the point it has become very
good at it so it can recognize any place
in the body
that's making these new antigens then
it is capable of fending off the
pathogen as you point out the
natural killer cells actually no the
natural killer t
cells uh will come in and kill
cells that have been infected by virus
and the body will in many ways clear
the uh the infection these are the
cytolytic t cells
cytotoxic or cytotoxic t cells cytotoxic
t cells
okay so having done that so imagine you
got sick
you breathed in a virus maybe it was a
cold
it invaded some cells those cells
started to make viral particles
those particles got recognized by the
adaptive immune system
the immune system got very good at
becoming specific and
targeting those antigens the affinity
for the antigens went
up and then you eventually clear the
infection because your system is good at
recognizing it
and then your system goes and it
produces memory cells
these memory cells remember the formula
so that if
they are triggered again they can
immediately create a large
army of cells that are very specifically
targeted at that pathogen
still right yeah yeah sure okay good
um and then you point out that the
uh helper t cells are actually
involved in helping to trigger b cell
immunity
in the adaptive immune system having
discovered the formula for
uh for the particular pathogen yeah well
this process that you were describing
maturation
and acquisition of memory
is the help cell dependent it depends on
the support the assistance of the helper
cells
great and so in the context of covid
people will have heard
a discussion about whether or not the
infection with the virus or the
vaccination
triggers a robust b cell response they
will
we will be able to detect an antibody
titer that is the degree
of antibodies that we find a deeper
question is how
how well how much affinity do the
antibodies have
for the antigen in question which will
vary based on whether or not we're
talking about
the variant of the virus that the
vaccine was built
to recognize or a new variant right so
the
affinity could drop but wouldn't drop to
zero
and then there's a question about
whether or not
the system that creates the antibodies
which would create a short-term immunity
has converted over into a system of
memory
that would allow long-term immunity to
exist so we talk about
the cellular immunity having been
acquired
and that is much harder to test for it's
very easy to test for antibodies
uh in the system so you get the vaccine
your antibody titer goes up we can
measure that with a simple blood test
testing whether or not you have
long-term immunity based in cells that
have a correct memory
is tougher but still possible am i right
yeah but the b cells also do have memory
right and in order to
to to get that memory you have to boost
uh
you have to you need to boost an
injection for the most of the vaccines
so it's not just uh it's not just the t
cells that have memory it's also the b
cells and you need that memory also of
the b cells in order to
uh to recall your antibodies upon the
re-exposure of course to
to the virus or to the antigen so you
have as well b
cell memory as t cell memory great
okay and um the
so people can also now understand in
some sense why some of these vaccines
require two doses
right so the vaccine is um
entering your cells let's take one of
the mrna vaccines
as an example the mrna which encodes
uh the spike protein is introduced it is
taken up by
cells and actually i'm a little unclear
on why
the lipid nanoparticles cause it to be
taken up into cells given
this is effectively like a synthetic
virus that we introduce
an mrna surrounded by lipid
nanoparticles
can you explain why it is taken up by
the host cells in the lipid nanoparticle
these lipid nano particles will simply
enhance uh the
uptake of the because you could say if
you would have the
mrna as such it would be very soluble
and you know it could go anywhere
whereas the lipid nanoparticle has a
higher
affinity i would say for the cell the
cell membrane
because of all kinds of interactions you
could say hydrophobic interactions
between the lipids
and and the organic phase of the of the
cell membrane
so that will enhance the uptake of the
uh
of the mrna because of the particulate
structure one
and second because of the physical
chemical nature of
uh of this particle which is now a lipid
nanoparticle and also the size
uh dental sized particles are readily
taken up into
what we call you know uh
well as well antigen presenting cells as
normal cells for example it will it will
it will promote and it will enhance the
entry of the mrna
in the in the target cell okay beautiful
so i think what i've just heard you say
is that um you have an aqueous
environment that is to say a wet
environment of the blood and the lymph
they're primarily
made of water the cells are surrounded
by fat which
is obviously not water soluble and by
putting
the mrna inside effectively
a globule of fat nanoparticles
the affinity for the cell these
basically drives these
mrnas into the cells which then
transcribe them because one of the
things that goes on inside of cells
is that mrna is transcribed just to do
the normal business of the cell itself
okay great so what we've done so far is
we've talked
about the adaptive immunity system
which through a process called clonal
selection actually evolves
to be able to target and eliminate
or control an infection once acquired
but this is not the full basis of our
immunity to pathogens in the world
we also have innate immunity that is to
say immunity that does not require
exposure in order to develop so can you
describe the basis of innate immunity
well i'm going to limit myself to
the equivalent the the humor all
so the antibody part and the cellular
part of the innate immunity because that
is really what is most
important for this discussion so as you
were pointing out you have the
antibodies as you described being part
of the
innate immunity uh sorry a big part of
the acquired immunity
specifics are first of all they
specifically recognize an antigen
and they can also induce memory these b
cells can have memory and therefore
produce
antibodies that will readily recognize
the antigen upon the re-exposure so the
equivalent in the innate immune in
innate immunity are what we call natural
antibodies those natural antibodies
are produced by what we call an
innate like b cell right this is a b
cell that is already pre-programmed it's
already present at birth
right so these natural antibodies in
contrast
to the antibodies produced by the b
cells of the
acquired imbued system uh have no
antigen specific
specificity they can recognize multiple
antigens
and they are not recalled upon
re-exposure
so that is the humeral part of the
innate immune system
then the cellular part the cellular part
is in contrast to the t cells we were
talking about
not able to recognize a specific antigen
that is
presented for example or on an infected
cell
but that the cells that uh
of the innate immune cell of the native
immune system
we call them natural natural killer
cells like
you have the natural antibodies of the
innate immune system you have the
natural
killer cells of the innate immune system
they recognize
in a non-specific way a kind of array
of motifs on the surface of an infected
or pathologically altered cell like a
cancer cell for example
they will recognize motifs a pattern of
motifs
so this is not very specific for an
antigen but
if for example a virus invades that cell
and there are
some proteins that are presented on the
surface or some glycogens
then these glycogens for example will
build a pattern
and these patterns will be recognized by
the nk cells
in case cells again have no memory
but they can act very very fast like the
natural antibodies they are already
there they are pre-armed they are
pre-pre-programmed so they act
immediately this is really
the first line of immune defense when a
pathogen gets in
fascinating okay so you have a system
that reacts
more or less to the symptoms at the
cellular level
of pathology the cells are behaving
molecularly in an
unusual way that triggers these natural
killer cells and they don't need to
learn any new tricks
but they also are limited in their
capacity because they are not specific
so they can recognize
the pathology and react but to
specifically recognize the pathogen
and its molecular consequences
requires this acquired immunity all
right
now i hope we haven't antagonized people
by leading them through that biology but
i know from experience that listening to
conversations about covid
if you don't have this basic level you
can't understand what's being said and
why it might be true you have no
it it doesn't uh it doesn't add up the
complexity of this system is inherent
to understanding uh how it works and
what is reasonable to do in response
so all right let us get into your
argument
about the hazard of our current
vaccine regime and let me say you have
made some very strong claims you have
argued
that in fact the vaccine campaign that
we are currently engaged in is so
dangerous
that it should be halted and
i will say i don't know if you're right
i cannot
i cannot determine based on what i
understand if you're right but what i
can
say is that you are making sense
right this is frightening in and of
itself that your argument
is completely coherent whether or not it
is true
this is at least a question that should
be engaged by those who are making
policy around this because
the possibility of making our viral
situation with respect to covid
worse is present and
you know we we are creating the hazard
of the future that we will be
confronting a year or two down the road
by our actions now and so
um were we to have reacted differently
at the beginning of kovid we might not
be in the situation we're in now
were we to act differently now we will
be in a different situation
years down the road and so we are always
sort of setting the stage of our next
battle and it is in that context that we
have to engage your argument and take it
quite seriously so what in a nutshell
is your argument for the hazard that we
may be creating
so my argument is first of all
as i was always saying these vaccines
are
would be perfect to be used
outside of a pandemic why i'm saying
this
because if you use them if you use
vaccines
before you get exposed to the virus
well in this case it's a virus you can
build
a full-fledged immunity as you were
pointing out this takes time
most of the current vaccines even
require two doses
you have been pointing out about this
this clonal expansion
in the meantime you acquire memory
you acquire higher affinity etc this is
a process before you acquire the
full-fledged immunity
so if you have this full-fledged
immunity
and then you get exposed to the pathogen
you literally have
everything you need to fight off this
pathogen
right and and there is absolutely no
problem and that's what i'm
always what i have always been saying
i'm not talking about
maybe secondary uh effects or
adverse events etc this is not my
field of specialty other people can
discuss this so i'm not talking about
really the quality of the vaccines or
adverse events but in principle
this is a correct vaccine to be used
outside of a pandemic so let me just
pause you there
let's say just hypothetically speaking
let's say that the virus had
emerged in wuhan and
the world had limited its spread let's
say that it was
kept to eurasia
and the rest of the world had not faced
the
virus then if we took one of these
mrna vaccines for example and vaccinated
the population
so that 80 90 percent of the population
was vaccinated before
encountering the virus before the virus
crossed any ocean for example
then we would expect this to work very
well
sure and the hazard of it would be low
even if it was true that it only
produced
let's say 80 percent
uh immunity and even if it was true
that people shed some people who
were vaccinated but then became infected
did shed some virus and occasionally
infected other people
is that fair to say that this would
still be a reasonable
yes a reasonable campaign yeah the only
thing i would like to add rich just to
be clear
for the audience is that here we are
talking about the original virus about
the wild virus the original gohan virus
right we are not yet talking about
variants
right under that assumption what you're
saying is
perfectly correct and fine because
even if you don't
prevent infection completely and you
diminish
only the viral load as long as the virus
will have not will not have enough
opportunity because the infectious
pressure is so low
to propagate it will it will die out
so that is perfectly fine and and and so
you can control it
so this is the thing that i think is too
subtle for most people to to get
and hopefully we can help them see the
difference
the vaccine from the point of view of
the patient the patient goes
they get they you know go through
whatever anxiety they have about needles
and
unknown hazards of vaccines and they get
their shot that looks the same
to people whether they're being
vaccinated in the midst of a pandemic or
in advance of a pandemic
but from the point of view of the
evolutionary landscape
these two things are completely
unrelated right
introducing the vaccine when the the
virus has
already gotten a foothold and has
started to diversify
getting a vaccine is actually you know
it's like
showing up imagine that your nation was
being invaded
right and there's a question about how
useful
your rifle is when
the ship you know some little boat with
12 people on it shows up on the shore
your rifle might be very useful right if
you show up with that same rifle
against an army of 10 000
you're gonna get shot and you know you
may actually be in a worse position
because you'll give away
you know you're shaking your finger
especially if this happens before you
can completely charge your rifle
your arm is not fully charged and you
are already under attack
right already under attack so this is i
mean in some sense
this is uh this is very straightforward
to me because i'm used to thinking in
evolutionary terms
right and so the idea of
to me the virus looks very different
even though the particles may be very
similar to each other
the virus looks very different when it
has
a huge number of individuals in which to
engage in evolutionary experimentation
versus a tiny number of individuals
where the chances of it happening on
anything useful are very small right
once you've got the huge canvas the
chances that the virus is going to learn
new tricks are
a hundred percent and in fact it's doing
it and you know as i said at the top
no surprise at all that us having
botched the initial reaction to the
virus which frankly
in my opinion should have been much
stronger right we should have had a much
more
intensive campaign to to control the
spread of the virus
early on and we might not be dealing
with this you know
half-assed long-term uh
you know set of measures that are
increasingly draconian and having all
sorts of other effects a short
intense uh control effort would have
been more effective
in part the reason that i say that is
because
it's just much easier to address you
know if this was an invasive species
and there are 10 individuals right
finding them is very uh effective you
could find them you can eliminate them
you're done once the thing has covered
the landscape
it's a whole different puzzle even if
the uh the individual
uh critters aren't very different
so all right we've got a difference
between
these vaccines and their utility in
advance of a pandemic versus
in the pandemic we are in the pandemic
and now what do you see the hazard being
of
a mass vaccine campaign
well so these vaccines will definitely
induce an immune response that's what we
have been explaining
so what we know is that
it takes time to develop an immune
response
so during that time your immune response
is not optimal
right it's not fully mature that is one
thing
the other thing is we are already
dealing
before we started the mass vaccination
campaign
before they got rolled out properly we
had already variants
so again the immune response
that you are mounting when you have been
vaccinated
is suboptimal towards a variant
that has a spike protein which is
different from the spike protein in the
vaccine
so the vaccinal antibodies against the
spike protein
are suboptimal because the s-protein
of the variant is not the same so we are
when we when we are vaccinating people
as i was saying
you're you are going to war but
your arm isn't charged yet you are
already fully under attack and you still
need to mount this antibody response
and you are attacked by things that you
have not learned to properly recognize
so the immune response is suboptimal so
now
so this creates what we call an immune
pressure
a pressure it's suppressed it's
definitely a pressure on the virus the
the the virus isn't happy with with with
his immune response
but it is going to be able to adapt
to that immune pressure why am i saying
this i'm saying this because
when you have whenever you have to
adapt a virus or a microorganism but i'm
talking about viruses
to unfavorable conditions let's let's
let's say you you would like to do this
in the lab
you have a virus and you would like it
to adapt the virus to an unfavorable
condition
that unfavorable condition could be
cultivating for example
an influenza virus on eggs instead of on
a cell culture
or incubating your virus on a
temperature that is not ideal for the
cells to grow and for the virus to
produce
but it could also be the unfavorable
condition could also be
an immune pressure antibodies for
example that are
present so if you would like to do this
in the lab
you would like to adapt a virus to
unfavorable conditions what you would do
is you would take that virus and you
would put it on a cell line
in the presence of those unfavorable
conditions so in this
in this case it would be a optimal
antibody dose let's say
but then that is not sufficient because
of course you have always and that is
the argument of many people yeah you
have all the time variants and mutations
etc
of course but now you will select
certain mutations that are capable
of dealing with this unfavorable
condition
right so you will select those variants
but that is not sufficient
because it's not because you have done
this selection one single time
that this variant is now going to become
dominant in the population
it will still have a very low we call
this a viral title
a very low concentration but now
if you take that virus or you know the
all these viruses
and you're now going to inoculate this
on another cell culture
under the very same conditions of immune
pressure
and then you do it again and again and
again
then ultimately this mutant
will adapt to these unfavorable
conditions
and it will have a competitive advantage
compared to the original viruses
and that is how you know in the course
of time
this population of these mutants that
originally were only presently very low
concentration
will now become predominant so now you
trans uh you extrapolate this to two
people
what you're gonna do in order to be able
to
adapt to adapt a viral mutant
you would need to passage a virus
from one person to the other but in
order for that virus to be able to adapt
it would be important that these people
are under the same immune pressure also
experiencing a situation
of suboptimal immune response and what
i'm saying is that
if you're already having variants before
you start your vaccination campaign
and then you're immunizing in the heat
of the pandemic
where while the immune response is built
up
you're already under attack many many
people of course in such situations
are going to be to be experiencing a
suboptimal immune response
and hence this will enable mutants that
occasionally emerge of course to adapt
and to gain a competitive advantage and
to become dominant in that population
and then of course we have a problem
because this is what we call selective
selective immune escape you select it
and you enable the virus to adapt to
that situation so it becomes predominant
and that is what we are seeing right now
as soon as you have an infectious
variant popping up
guess what i mean it takes like a few
weeks or it becomes predominant in in
the population
okay so let us build on the
analogy of uh of
war to to see your argument more clearly
we send soldiers to war we send them to
boot camp first
okay boot camp is like the vaccine right
we expose them to something that is war
like without there being an actual enemy
so that
the soldiers can learn to fight that
enemy in a comparatively safe context
before they face the actual enemy
if you send your soldiers to the front
before you send them to boot camp not
only will they be vulnerable
but they will end up training the enemy
on how to exploit their weaknesses right
you want to eliminate the weaknesses
first and so in effect what you are
saying
is that by deploying this vaccine in the
context of an
epidemic already underway we are
effectively sending
soldiers to the front and we are yes it
is true that the soldiers will learn to
fight on the front to the extent that
they can survive
but they will also teach the enemy to
fight even better so you are entering
an arms race at a disadvantage rather
than an advantage
now if we extend the metaphor a little
bit
let's imagine so the whole system
functions based on the ability to
recognize the enemy and
see it very clearly right you could
imagine on the battlefield this would
make sense too
to the extent that some enemies are very
good at camouflaging themselves those
enemies tend to persist
to the extent that some enemies are
obvious they tend not to persist because
they get
shot so imagine that we did some trick
with the camouflage that the
soldiers on the front wore where those
that persisted the longest their
camouflage
spread itself and those that died early
their camouflage went extinct right so
over time the camouflage would get
better and better
by exerting this pressure you are
arguing
and i think there's no question that
this is accurate
we are effectively running what would in
the laboratory be called a serial
passage
experiment we are creating those exact
conditions
in a context where there's a huge
landscape of virus
already adapting to the inability of the
immune system to see certain things
and i would add one thing to your
description so far
which is that the nature of these
vaccines
part of the magic of them the ability to
generate them so quickly
has to do with how utterly narrowly
focused
they are instead of doing something
traditional like taking a virus
and inactivating it and introducing the
whole virus
into the body so the body sees the whole
thing
right we've narrowed the focus down to
the spike protein itself
and not only that we've narrowed it down
to the spike protein of the original
virus
and this has created a very concentrated
pressure
which means that we're trying to inform
the immune system of exactly what the
enemy looks like
and we've honed in on one characteristic
and that means that if the virus can
change that one characteristic
then suddenly it becomes invisible and
so we are effectively setting ourselves
up for an evolutionary
failure by concentrating our response
and introducing it on the front rather
than in advance of the encounter and
you know again i don't know that your
argument is right but i can
say it's very clearly plausible
and the hazard is potentially immense
so the thing i would like to to add to
this brett
which is a very objective argument
we absolutely need because otherwise we
not not the both of us but the community
is going to turn
around in circles and of course i can
understand that the resistance
is enormous but we absolutely need
criteria that we agree upon
that would that would uh enable us
to distinguish whether human
intervention whether this is mass
vaccination or the mass prevention if
infection prevention measures are both
combined
in use in uniscape so what
would be the criteria that would be
generally acknowledged and accepted
would this be for example dramatic
increase of
more infectious variants for example
would this be resistance to the vaccines
ultimately
would this be that we have more
and more younger age groups that become
infected
so there is a number of criteria that
could be uh
defined and that according to my humble
opinion
clearly illustrates that there is a huge
impact of human intervention on the way
the virus evolves and on the collective
the collective immune response of the
population and the dynamics thereof
but as long as we don't agree on upon
this criteria my fear is that
mass vaccination will continue no matter
what
till everybody gets vaccinated it's no
longer a question
of immune defense building an immune
defense it becomes a question of
vaccinating everybody which is not the
same certainly not
within the context of this complex
phenomenon
the pandemic combined with human
intervention
yes so i i like what you're saying very
much about the criteria
i have a concern or two some of the
criteria
are likely to occur either way
so for example let's just take one you
talk about the
potential for the increasing
vulnerability of the young and we have
not yet described
why it is that the young might be
anomalously immune
to covid which they seem to be
we'll come back to that but one thing
that is certainly true
is that the young to the extent that
they do not seem to come down with covid
and when they get it don't seem to have
very severe disease in general
represent an opportunity for any variant
that can figure out how
to bypass effectively what must be their
innate immunity
that is preventing the disease so that
opportunity exists whether we
vaccinate or or we don't and it is in
fact one of the reasons
you know the argument that i would make
for a very intensive
campaign of behavior modification to
control the virus which
you know this the ship has sailed but we
should
very early on have treated this much
more carefully
because now that it is out in the world
in such large numbers
there is nothing to stop it from
discovering a pathway
to infect the young right it is always
hovering at the door
and it may eventually figure out how to
how to accomplish that just as it may
eventually figure out how to spread
outdoors something
that it does not seem to do well yet but
is an opportunity you know to the extent
that some of us
are using the outdoor environment uh
effectively to engage
in social behavior because the
environment itself protects us that's an
opportunity if a virus can figure out
how to
endure uv light or whatever else it's
doing so
how many of your criteria will
separate the natural evolution of the
virus
just by virtue of the fact that we have
an uncontrolled pandemic
from the evolution of the virus driven
by
a targeted broad-scale vaccine campaign
well that is exactly what the criteria
should be based upon
and i guess the only
comparator we have unfortunately is
almost like the flu pandemic
1918. why i'm saying this because this
was clearly
a pandemic of a respiratory virus
where there was no human intervention
infection prevention measures were very
very very
limited it was war on top so you had
crowding you had
very bad hygiene genie conditions etc
and there was no vaccine so there first
of all what we have seen we have seen no
variants
the whole thing happened within one year
and and people have been sampling
uh or analyzing autopsy samples to see
whether it was any variation in the in
this range that
you know during this pandemic appeared
in several different parts of of the
world
and it was very homologous so that is
one thing
now so that is that is very important
because this
is a high infectious pressure a natural
pandemic
no human intervention so if you imagine
now that we have
like every second or third week
we have a new uh infectious variant
appearing
and not only is this a more infectious
variant
it's very often also much more
infectious like in the brazilian
compared to the uk etc
and it all appears very rapidly it's not
like
during evolution of course you know
these things appear and if they have a
competitive advantage
they will replace the original strain
now all this is happening
multiple variants within a short period
of time
with dramatically increased infectivity
and this in parallel with with the mass
vaccination campaign
i mean as i was saying you have the same
pandemic
well it was flu of course nothing
happens in
in terms of variance there were a few
mutations but
here the mutations are very clearly
targeted they are selected
at domains that enhance the infectivity
files so they are not like random they
are really selected
towards parts of the of the spy protein
that are responsible for effectivity
so i mean there is something there
right oh yes we need to agree upon this
same same for example if you look if you
imagine now the
the the situation in chile for example
okay so you are
vaccinating you're vaccinating on a
background
of a variant that had just appeared
right i mean the brazilian
the brazilian variant so this brazilian
variant is of course pretty much
different
the s protein from the s-protein of the
vaccine
if you now start vaccinating people of
course
this variant that just emerged
is going to have a competitive advantage
because it's more infectious and what
you want to do with your antibodies is
to prevent infectivity
so now all of a sudden you see how this
variant is exploding
and you see the infectious rates that
are dramatically increasing
so all of a sudden you have a much
higher infectivity rate right
and so there is other criteria as well
that we could uh
the mutations are of course studied and
we see more and more that
they are also now converging towards
domains
that are targeted by the vaccinal
antibodies
so if you take all these things together
we we
should be able compared as you pointed
out correctly to a natural pandemic
to observations that are really high
very very strange
and that according to my humble opinion
could be correlated
with at least i would say human
intervention right in this pandemic
so uh if i can make that a little bit
simpler what you're saying is a
something that surprised me the first
time i heard you say it which is that in
the
um the 1918 pandemic there was
apparently
there were no widespread variants and we
know this
from the comparison of samples taken
during
autopsy so that shocks me i think what
it suggests
is that the evolutionary experimentation
took place before the pandemic that
effectively the virus got very effective
at uh transmitting in some small
population that wasn't captured
in the autopsy samples maybe it wasn't
even recognized as a unique disease
and that by the time it circulated
around the globe
it was already highly effective and that
in this case
we have well a i would say the anomalous
fact
of this virus apparently having emerged
in the human population
already highly effective we have no
evidence for that experimental
evolutionary period at the beginning
which is one of the reasons that many of
us believe
the laboratory origins hypothesis is
probably correct
but in the context of this
vaccine campaign what you're arguing is
that we are seeing
exactly the pattern of change that you
would predict if we were creating this
inadvertent
serial passage experiment in the human
population we are putting pressure
on the spike protein in this narrow way
we are seeing change in the spike
protein and in exactly the domains that
would
cause immune escape and that you know
uh the let's put it this way i think the
um
presumption would have to be that we are
driving that change or at least
accelerating that change by virtue of
the very intense and very
narrow evolutionary pressure that we are
applying to the virus
well frankly speaking brett if you would
ask me
set up an experiment where you adapt
a variant to immune pressure but do it
in humans or do you do it in a mammalian
population
what would you do you would of course
first of all
make sure you have a high viral load
you would make sure that as many people
as possible
are in the same situation of a
suboptimal
immune in your response and
i mean if you have already if you can
already start with variance where the
match
is already suboptimal then it's even
better
right so that is exactly what you would
do that is exactly what you would do to
adapt and what
what is worrisome right is the the
kinetics of all these
this is all going very very fast right
i mean the appearance the emergence of
all these variants and i i mean
as i was saying there is probably a
whole series of variants that
have not been identified yet then and
but it's not
like any variance many of these variants
are selected towards for example a
higher
higher infectivity and when we come now
more and more with antibodies etc we see
already that
some of these mutations are uh
abolishing the effect of certain
antibodies within within the polyclonal
serum
of the vaccinal antibodies so it is very
well
directed it is fast it is pretty huge
because i mean
as i was saying if there is a a mutation
just by
an antigenic uh drift for example
and that mutation happens to be a little
bit more
infectious than the original strain then
in the course of time
it will take over but this will be
pretty slow right
evolutionary speaking here these things
are like accelerated enhanced
and it's difficult to deny that this is
not really
in parallel with with with the mass
vaccination campaigns or with with human
intervention
because as i was saying during the the
flu pandemic nothing was
seen and you could argue as well people
must have mounted uh antibody responses
right
during the flu pandemic i mean it was
not like
there was no immune response so
um you have said if you were going to
set up an experiment
to induce the
effectively gain of function here it
would look more or less like
this campaign i would say evolutionarily
we can describe this very simply that
effectively we have given
the virus a gentle evolutionary
evolutionary
slope for which it can discover
high infectivity and escape from
immune surveillance so that's all
um that's all quite
frightening that not only does the
pattern
in the wild seem to match the fears of
somebody
uh who is well positioned to say here's
what you would expect to see if my
hypothesis
is correct about um about immune escape
so that that raises a number of
different questions i mean it raises the
question about
what should we be doing vaccine wise
well brett i i'm a little bit hesitating
if for a second we should come back to
the innate
immune response oh and the connection to
the young
because because i mean you could say
well if there is a mute escape
worst case scenario is that the vaccine
won't work anymore
and that is then the other argument we
will produce new vaccines right
but my main argument really that is my
key
argument is that
even though the antibodies may no longer
neutralize the virus they will still be
able to bind to the spy protein
and all this is is signs because people
have been showing that for example
antibodies against the common cold virus
right they do not neutralize or cross
neutralize
uh cov19 for example or sars cov2
but they do bind they do bind to this
protein but they do not neutralize it
so if antibodies are no longer
completely functional in the sense that
they can neutralize the virus they can
still bind
bind to the s protein and there comes my
big argument and therefore
we need to come back to these natural
antibodies
by binding to the s protein
these antigens specific antibodies
are capable of out competing natural
antibodies
and that is that is the disaster because
as we were saying at the beginning the
natural antibodies
they are not antigen specific they have
the capacity
to broadly neutralize not only all kinds
of
covid variants but even all types of
corona viruses
and maybe you want to jump in at this
point to to make it a little bit clearer
too
sure yeah this is such a fascinating
point but uh what we have
is the possibility of antibodies that
are ineffective
at preventing the spike protein from
binding the receptor and therefore
ineffective at preventing infection
that would nonetheless attach themselves
electromagnetically they would just
simply
stick to the spike protein and they
would block the innate immunity
that we all have some degree of and that
young people appear to have a great deal
of
and therefore take the immunity that
works best and neutralize it without
creating a new immunity that would take
its place
that's um you know again that's a it's a
wild
argument but i see nothing wrong with it
logically logically speaking
this makes a great deal of sense well
you know brett
i i'm going to be very open with you the
the field
of natural antibodies is
not well recognized or known in the
field of vaccinology
it is well known by immunologists
frankly speaking there are there is
dozens of papers on these natural
antibodies and how fascinating they are
as i was saying they are a little bit
you know in parallel to the nk cells
they
recognize patterns they recognize
patterns of antigens
but um this field
is is so neglected so underestimated
i i'm sure that many vaccinologists
don't even
really understand what natural
antibodies are about and what they can
do
because there is a lot of documentation
on this and there is even documentation
i will tell you i will tell you the
nicest documentation is
you know about the blood groups right
ado etc
so these blood groups these are
glycosylated structures
right glycans sugars for the people who
don't understand what glycans are
and so for example if you have uh if
your blood group
group is o for example you will have
antibodies natural antibodies all
documented all in papers in publications
you will have natural antibodies
against for example the blood group
a blood group a is
a sugar and acet acetyl
uh galactosamine right and
so now interestingly enough if
the virus is now grown in a cell
in a mammalian cell in a target cell
that belongs to somebody who has
blood group a right then
as the virus is budding when the virus
is
leaving it's released from the cell
membrane
it has an envelope of course that
envelope because
it's partly you know part of the
membrane of the target cell it will
also have this blood group a antigen
and when such a virus is encountered
by somebody who has blood group o and
who has
natural antibodies against blood group a
this will the virus will be destroyed
and this has been proven
not for sarsko v2 but for sarsko with
one
that these natural antibodies will
prevent
the virus and the s antigen from
interacting with the ac2 receptors
right i mean it's not like there is no
evidence there is no points
also the binding forces between the
multimeric natural antibodies
and the specific specific antibodies
are completely different you know the
the type of chemical bonds
the one is the multivalent interaction
which is
much weaker than the specific binding
for example
i mean there is many many things
documented there is
also very well documented that natural
antibodies
can prevent influenza infection against
a whole range of variants
all this is in the literature so it's
not like
i'm the crazy guy just inventing some
stuff and
making putting uh pieces of a puzzle
that doesn't exist in reality together
to make a fancy story right it is it is
really
it is really highly likely that if you
have a specific antibodies
binding but not neutralizing your virus
that they can prevent the natural
antibodies from
from acting on that virus and that is as
you pointed out
your specific antibodies are no longer
functional
and you have no substitute for it
because
you put your natural antibodies out of
business
so this potentially puts the young at
risk who are largely protected because
it is presumably their innate immunity
that is
functioning to keep them safe so i want
to
clarify a little bit in here a
it is uh a very familiar pattern
that medicine and medical science will
ignore the parts of the system that work
well
without intervention in other words the
idea that we
are much more familiar with adaptive
acquired immunity
and just so happens that there are lots
of interventions that we deploy that
depend on it
and that we are largely ignorant of this
alternative kind of immunity because
effectively it just simply functions
uh without largely our awareness of it
um
is that's a classic pattern and
the uh the fact
so members of my audience will remember
when heather and i started doing
our live streams about kovid
we were struck many times at the
accumulating evidence not unlike
for other pathogens but there's a piece
of evidence that suggests
that whether or not you get sick is
heavily dosage dependent that
effectively
even if you are in a room with an
infected person and you are there very
briefly
that you don't tend to pick up the virus
but if you talked if you were there for
five minutes
you effectively fill some kind of bucket
and that once that bucket overflows
you're likely to get
the virus so on the one hand this
creates a whole landscape of advice that
we can give
about how to behave to reduce your risk
like opening windows and
being in large volume environments etc
but
effectively that piece of evidence
implies
the innate immunity system that
basically you have a system
that is capable of recognizing in a
not very specific way a wide range
of particles and it can deal with them
until it is overwhelmed that is to say
when you have just simply too many viral
particles so that your entire innate
immunity that is capable of dealing with
this virus
is occupied then that leaves some of
these viral particles
uh unhindered yeah right
yeah sorry go ahead go ahead no so all
i'm saying is that
it's interesting we have seen patterns
here that are suggestive
of the importance of innate immunity in
the covet 19 story in a way that
you know is underappreciated and the
idea that now
we're talking about uh rendering that
immune system
the innate immune system ineffective
uh at the same time we are failing to
create proper immunity in the adaptive
immune system that is
you know it's a perfect storm at some
level right we're taking the thing that
works
and upending it without creating the
thing that would replace it and
uh it does seem a very frightening
prospect
so the the the errors the error
comes from the fact that as i was saying
normally
adaptive immunity is a fantastic thing
it's a fantastic thing because it's
very quick it's very very specific it's
it's really
up to target but for example if you have
let's say you you would have adaptive
immunity let's say
against influenza right
and all of a sudden bread all of a
sudden
you have a dramatic change in the
antigen
we call this an antigenic shift right
then the adaptive immunity will not work
anymore
right but the innate immunity will still
work
and many many people have never been
vaccinated you know they will simply
deal with influenza
no problem so this adaptive
part that has now been subverted so to
say by the virus by the antigenic
shift you will have an outbreak of
course
right and what is happening here with
the immune escape
is that we are also creating an
antigenic shift but it's not static
it's dynamic the more we vaccinate the
more it's going to change
so we can never solve this normally if
you have an antigen
you will have an outbreak and then again
the
the collective immunity of the
population can can can deal with this
but here we are always changing the
entity
so the adaptive immunity cannot cope
cannot deal with this
and that is why here in a kind of
exceptional situation
the innate immunity becomes so important
when people talk about
herd immunity i'm always saying the real
hurt immunity that we have here
is innate immunity because
if you have this infection 80 percent of
the population
in some populations depending on age and
the demographics even
85 percent of the population eliminates
the virus and doesn't have
any symptoms isn't that isn't that
fantastic herd immunity
this is due to innate immunity we know
in the elderly the innate immunity is
weakened
and due to aging and these are the guys
who first
get get severe disease so the whole
immunity is here
due to innate immunity right and that is
the complete misunderstanding
yep now this uh tracks perfectly with
uh what i understand of the system and
it does
raise the specter that our intervention
is actually not only going to
become ineffective but render things far
worse than they are that in fact
we you know we take the immunity
of the young to covet 19
as somehow god-given and permanent and
it is anything but it is dependent on a
system we know
not enough about and that system is
capable of being disrupted by
a ham-fisted intervention in the
adaptive immunity system that uh
strikes me as all too plausible and i
would actually point out
uh it occurred to me when you were
speaking earlier that
there are lots of familiar examples
where the same
kind of overly simplistic logic has
failed us for exactly the same
reason so people who have
been prescribed an antibiotic by a
doctor for an infection
know full well this counterintuitive
advice that even after you've gotten
better you should finish
the course of antibiotics and most
people know why you were advised this
and that's because
you will surely feel better before
you've completely eliminated the
pathogen
and if you withdraw the antibiotic
before you are done with the course what
you have then done is trained
the remaining members of this population
to you know you have selected for those
members of the population of the
bacterium or the fungus
that were most resistant to the bacteria
uh you have selected
four of those and then if you withdraw
the uh the antibiotic then that
population
uh regenerates and what you've done is
you've induced
resistance and so we now know that we
have a population level
problem with induced resistance and
we've seen the same thing with
pesticides where
we think oh this pesticide is going to
eliminate malaria or
it's going to eliminate this pest from
the crop but effectively
we've entered an arms race we're
incapable of winning and made things
worse in many cases
so people say uh yeah i know that many
people i think
what i'm saying is is crazy because it
has never happened before
but never ever in the whole history of
mankind
have we been doing anything like this we
massively intervene in this pandemic you
know infection prevention measures
worldwide and pretty stringent and then
on top of this
mass vaccination in the midst of the
pandemic we have never
ever been doing a thing like this and
then saying what you're saying
doesn't make sense because it has never
happened before and
i'm saying well the situation we have
never generated we have never created a
situation like this
right it's it's novel either way all
right
so i would like to talk a little bit
more
about if you are correct about the
hazard here
uh my guess i think as you have already
said
is that there's no stopping this
campaign that is
in some sense politically inconceivable
that people would change course
even if it made perfect sense for them
to do so
and so the criteria you suggest might
tell us
that uh your model is correct um
standard
hypothetical deductive science you've
put out a hypothesis here are the
characteristics that you would expect to
indicate that it's right
if it turns out it's right what do we do
next
do you have a sense well
do you mean in terms of to remedy the
situation uh
[Music]
i mean my point is uh
you know the best thing that can happen
to somebody
is to to to be sero-negative right
because if you're set or negative
certainly certainly if you are
in good health and your sero-negative
you have good uh natural antibodies
again
this is no fantasy there are studies
scientific studies where
even natural antibodies are defined
or are used as a benchmark for good
health
right so if you're seronegative
you you don't suffer from any antibodies
that could block
your natural antibodies and
you can be fully exposed i mean of
course the problem is gonna be
the more you vaccinate people the more
people are gonna
gonna be sitting on long lift on
long-lived antibodies
right and even if those antibodies
decline
and they get re-exposed to the virus i
mean these antibodies will be
immediately recalled you were pointing
out you were educating people on what is
memory and how antibodies get recalled
upon re-exposure
right so
then you have of course uh well being
zero negative is not going to be easy
and i tell you why
because if we if we continue to breed
these highly infectious variants the
likelihood for somebody who is
seronegative
to become infected is is gonna become
higher and higher of course
so at the end of the day you can turn it
the way you want
for me there is only one solution at
this point in time
maybe not at the beginning where there
was a wild uh just the wild say
but at this point in time there is no
other solution but
better intervene and for me the the the
only intervention that makes sense is
really to eradicate
those uh those variance rings because
nobody is telling us
how we are ever gonna get rid of those
right
uh hurt immunity well i mean that's not
going to happen obviously because
you know we have it's not going to
happen because people will have been
exposed to different
variants and therefore it's
you know it's a family of viruses yeah
you know not uh not a single but
remember
this was the final target this was the
end game of the vaccination of the mass
vaccination
is to have hurt immunity right sure so
you could you could of course also and
i'm not the expert
but let's assume an antiviral would work
and this antiviral could even be things
like ivory meccan you you don't
hear me advocating for ivanka but let's
assume
some kind of antiviral drug would work
you could you could imagine to treat
also people with
with this antiviral but doing this in a
prophylactic way
you're going to have the same problem as
with antibiotics that
some people you know will have low
concentration be confronted with the
virus and
it will induce resistance i think uh at
the end
so you can use this for early treatment
that that i think is very very useful
but to get rid really of all these
variants
and to reduce the infectivity and
control the whole thing
i really see no other way but to have
a vaccine that induces you can maybe
explain this to the audience sterilizing
immunity
which is really to completely kill the
virus
no matter no no no matter what the
antigenic constellation is of the virus
but it is a variant so maybe i don't
know
well enough to explain it to the
audience i'd like to understand better
i certainly see that there is a hazard
a vaccine is not a vaccine right a
vaccine
is a very general technology and in this
case
the narrow targeting of the vaccine
seems to me
it was a blessing in the sense that it
allowed the vaccine to be generated very
quickly but it's a curse in the sense
that it informs the immune system only
about the one
characteristic and that if we were to
use something like
a an inactivated virus that the immune
system
could discover various antigens
and therefore the evolution of a single
antigen would not create the kind of
escape
that we're seeing but you tell me
whether that adds up no
no it doesn't i think it's a very
logical reasoning but unfortunately
uh it does not apply the reason is if
you target the s
protein what what most of these vaccines
do
you prevent you can prevent the virus
from entering into the cell
so that is basically that is that is
sufficient
if you know um
the problem is if you well let me put it
the other way around
instead of an inactivated virus
i think that might make sense because by
the way that is the way we eradicated
like uh smallpox that's also the uh
well the biggest rights in the
eradication of polio polio is not fully
eradicated but
almost but the biggest rights we have
made with the oral polio vaccine which
was also
a life attenuated vaccine and there of
course you induce
innate immune responses as well as of
course
adaptive immunity etc and that would be
i think in my humble opinion
much more efficient but of course it
would not be
uh a solution for people who have
already been
vaccinated because as i was saying if
you re-vaccinate them with the oral
polio
with the let's say an attenuated corona
virus you're gonna recall
their original antibodies first because
those have memory
and there is something like we call this
antigenic sin
if you are re-challenged with an
antigen that is similar to the one
to which you got originally primed then
your
original antibodies are going to be
recalled and those are
not going to match with with the
variance so you you are gonna
even promote again immune escape if you
re-vaccinate people who have previously
been vaccinated
with with the current vaccines but it
may help for those who are
negative so attenuated you're arguing
so the attenuated virus is one
that functions to transmit between
cells uh
that function to transmit well it's it's
live attenuate so it's going to be
uh secretly excreted right to some
extent
yeah some people will say it was also
the problem with with oral polio
that in at the end of the day you put
this in the environment
it gets again in people it can recombine
etc
but still as we have seen with oropolio
it has dramatically dramatically
reduced viral loads but my
understanding is because of this
antigenic sin that you could not
use it in people who have already been
pre-primed
with with the current vaccine right so
this is this is yet another argument
against the current regime is that the
current vaccine
regime actually eliminates what might be
our best weapon
going forward because it will induce a
kind of immunity that will react to
uh this alternative type of vaccine
this breath is something people need to
understand in contrast to
a drug you have a drug when that gets
eliminated from your blood
or you know you have the the the half
time of the
you need the minimum concentration for
the drug to be active
if you're below that concentration it
doesn't work anymore it's eliminated and
you're fine it's done you know
there is no there is no consequence so
to say
a vaccine is something that educates
your immune system for god's sake for
the rest of your life
right so that is not a simple thing that
is something which has serious
consequences i mean
we were talking about the memory what is
memory
well memory means that if you see this
antiquation
again or something alike your antibodies
your original immune response will be
recalled
right yes so that is a serious thing
i i've been trying to to call my
audience's attention to this that
we are inherently intervening
not just in a complex system right
complex systems are tough enough
but you're you're intervening in a
complex system within a complex system
within a complex system
right the narrowest one being the immune
system which you are educating
the immune system existing inside the
body which is itself an adaptive system
and then it exists inside a population
and so all of these things interact and
what they do
is they mean that any action that you
take because it sounds like the right
thing to do
risks creating a cascade of consequences
you did not anticipate
this being one such consequence that
there is a tool
that would take longer to develop that
you will take off the table to the
extent
that you have educated people's immune
system such that effectively
you've warned them about a pathogen your
next vaccine might be
attenuated and effectively the immune
system would have the equivalent of
post-traumatic stress disorder where it
would react
to the attenuated vaccine which is
potentially life-saving
it would react to it as if it were a
pathogen and it would prevent the
effectiveness
is that what you're saying well it will
recall your original antibodies and
these are the
s antibodies uh of the current vaccines
right
which uh which we know uh you know they
uh they
they don't do the job essentially let's
assume
you you make this vaccine and you start
vaccinating with it in half
half a year from now in the meantime
you will have further evolution of
course of your variance so they will
even be
more different the s-protein from the
one that was originally in the vaccine
so now when you recall the original
antibodies
in one in half a year from now yeah
for sure they will match
much less with with with the s protein
of the variants that will
be circulating in half a year from now
right so it's so it's further driving
immune escape
basically so for me and uh yeah i
i start uh you know to hate to say this
because people think that i'm selling my
business or whatever
but asymptomatic people asymptomatic
people they clear the virus
thanks to natural antibodies in
combination with nk cells again this is
science there's publications
or very compelling very very compelling
show
that um the combination of the natural
antibodies the natural antibodies so to
say as you were saying they
evacuate part of the virus so that you
know the concentration so to say
diminishes
and and so that the the chances that
you're going to get severe disease or
are diminished so they evacuate part of
the virus
and they bring it they they into the
nk cell pathway so that the virus can be
destroyed by the nk cells
and but in case else normally that's how
we started the discussion
have no memory so now there are tricks
and we know that to some extent
nk cells can acquire memory it has not
been proven for corona
but i think this is really a pathway to
work on because
if we know uh the motifs that the nk
cells recognize
we can use them in a vaccine and of
course we need to do
something about the memory but i'm
always giving the example maybe you have
heard about the
streptococcus vaccines the
polysaccharide vaccines
against pneumonia for example or type is
media etc that you you
you get you know during childhood
normally these
antigens polysaccharide sugars they
induce antibodies but without memory so
that's not good
so what we have been doing we have been
making a conjugate vaccine and we have
taken the polysaccharides and we have
conjugated them
to a t helper protein a t helper protein
and now with this synthetic construct
this is not a natural construct this is
something
man-made i think the biggest invention
ever in vaccinology
we have now managed to induce an immune
response that not only recognizes the
polysaccharides but that also has
memory thanks to this conjugate so in
other words
even though natural immune responses do
not have memory
we can educate the immune system in a
way that
it can get you know acquire memory
against this particular
patterns i would say so that's
fascinating yeah that
because this is non-antigen specific so
that means that cannot be immune
escape right escape against what
selection of what
it's it's non-antigen it's ant yeah
antigen non-specific
that's the right way to say all right
uh that's very interesting i did not
know about that construct but the idea
of creating basically hacking the system
to trigger
memory in a case where memory would not
ordinarily be developed is that's
fascinating
so um i had a thought here likely wrong
but when
triple drug cocktails emerged against
hiv
i had this moment where i had the sense
that it was obvious
that we should have done something like
this from the beginning because
effectively
by taking three different drugs and
challenging
the virus simultaneously with them we
eliminate the pathway by which we would
train
it against whatever our best drug was
because you sort of push it in three
directions at once and it can't
it can't adapt so evolutionarily
speaking i thought this was
straightforward that something like this
would work it doesn't have to be three
but
pushing it in more directions than it
can go makes sense
so by analogy um if you were to
uh set up conditions where
you know some sort of competition where
somebody
had to uh you know increase their
capacity to
high jump at the same time they
uh increased the amount of weight they
could lift
and uh conserved the maximum number of
calories all those things push in
different directions so the point is
there's no way to game any of these
systems you have to just sort of
compromise which makes you
low quality at all of them so i'm
wondering if there's not a vaccine
style solution here that involves
uh instead of pushing the virus in one
direction
and creating the immune escape pathway
that you describe
is there not some way of
formulating a challenge that pushes it
in
simultaneous mutually exclusive
directions
so that it cannot move
well of course i've been
torturing my brain you know
for like many years not because of this
corona thing
but as as you can imagine
we could have other pandemics as well to
which we are not prepared at all
so in other sense what has been the
focus in fact of my attention of my
rich research in the last eight years
has been
universal vaccines and universal
doesn't mean one vaccine for all kinds
of diseases no it
means one vaccine for a number of like
for example
natural antibodies as i was saying or nk
cells recognize
a pattern of motifs that may be
shared by several different pathogens
when they infect cells
right it's like a cancer cell at the
very beginning
the first alteration of the cancer cell
no matter what cancer it is
it's an alteration of self that's the
kind of common denominator
so it's a pattern that is shared among
several different
pathogens or pathogenic agents and
so how can you how can you make
such vaccines this is very challenging
but frankly speaking to cut
a very long story short that is why i
started to concentrate on nk cell based
vaccines
because the innate as we were saying the
innate immune cells
but we need to provide them with memory
of course
or in fact the only cells that have this
capacity
to recognize you know a wide array
of several different changes
on the surface of the cell and another
important thing is at a very very early
stage of infection
that's a very important thing because we
were talking about the t cells in the
cytolytic t
cells we know when people get a disease
for example severe disease
and then they cure it out it's to a
large extent thanks to
cytotoxic t cells but they come way too
late
what we need is the cell that the virus
gets into the cell there is an
alteration on the membrane before even
you have the progeny of the virus right
before you have
you know uh uh replication
uh and and and production of new virus
particles so at the very beginning
you have an alteration of the cell of
the cell membrane at a very early stage
that's where you need to kill this cell
and
i i'm not aware and and i don't don't
think it
exists that you could use multiple
multiple immune interventions at the
same time combine them
to cut let's say several different
pathways for the virus to
to generate a progeny and to propagate
because as soon brett as soon as you
come with several different
uh immunogenic uh agents you will have
competition as well
right you will have competition one will
be more dominant than the other
and will will take advantage of the
immune system and and use its full
capacity
and other immunogens you know they
they will barely generate any new
response because they are not dominant
right so there is one thing that i've
learned in immunology that does not
apply
which is the more the better that
doesn't apply
to immunity right the more debate that
does apply to drugs
very often it does not apply to
immunology people always think
oh wow this vaccine doesn't work we give
double dose or we
we we give another dose after three
weeks and then one month
and etc so the more the more the better
that's not
that's that doesn't work in immunology
that doesn't work in vaccinology
it's a message that you convey to the
immune system yes for
for multiple reasons it doesn't work so
to the extent that you have informed
your immune system about a particular
challenge it's informed right informing
it
sending it you know a thousand emails
that share the same piece of information
doesn't inform it better
then there's also the problem of uh
autoimmunity and leukemia right so
the point is it's not just a question of
the information
which uh the value of which a single
email will do
or a single vaccine that is effective at
creating
memory will do but there's also the
problem that this system
is very tightly managed for health
and that at some level i'm pretty sure
we don't know
what the result of continuing to trigger
it
in various ways is and you know
uh unregulated production of uh b
cells for example uh would be a
known type of tumor it's uh uh would be
leukemia right
and uh autoimmunity would be the
reaction of the immune system
to uh things that you yourself make and
so the point is
messing with this system when you don't
know what you're doing carries all kinds
of potential hazards
and we have to be very careful with it
and unfortunately i think the political
environment in which we find ourselves
makes it very hard to behave rationally
that there is a demand
on people who are um in a position to
govern
that they do something and the problem
is very few appreciate just how delicate
this system is
and how marvelously it's working on
their behalf already i mean yes covet is
frightening
but the degree to which most of us have
not
gotten it is uh owing to
the effectiveness of the system uh
before you make any intervention at all
yeah yeah the immune system is extremely
sophisticated
and for example i posted on my website a
number of maybe
15 maybe 20 15 let's say
questions that are really fundamental
questions
things we don't understand uh you know
in the pathobiology
of of covet 19 and
a number of questions surrounding of
course the the the immunology and the
immune defense
and i think if you cannot answer to this
fundamental questions i mean it becomes
very very
tricky to intervene in the immune system
and
certainly certainly if you intervene at
a very very large scale
knowing that the message we were talking
about will stay with you for the rest of
your life
right so that is something really i
um yeah i i think there we should have
done a much
much better homework because
massive intervention in in something
which is so well
tuned so so sophisticated uh
either you have a fantastic effect or uh
you know
if you do this on a massive scale or
it's uh
it's all but good and uh
that is that is really my fear right now
with uh what is happening and the
terrain which seemingly we we will
not be able to stop anymore yes
uh i think in some sense to continue
with the military analogy
this is a live fire exercise in which
we're all in unfortunately that's an
experience yes
it's an experiment and a very poorly
uh a very poorly controlled one which is
uh frightening
all right where can people find you
well people can find me uh based on my
website uh because unfortunately
although
i try to distribute
you know scientific information and only
scientific information it gets
increasingly
blocked on all kinds of channels and
media
so um my
my website is uh gear vandenbosch
and then um dot org
org okay
gert vandenbusch.org i know that you're
also
on twitter and that your website can be
found through your twitter
bio i will say to the extent that people
that platforms are taking down the
material that you're putting up
this is madness no i know right this is
madness you are a domain expert
you are clearly
motivated by concern
what you're saying is whether or not it
is correct
it is perfectly rational it is
highly logical and can be interpreted by
anyone who has uh
the scientific training enough to follow
such an
argument that the idea that you are
somehow
a hazard um by virtue
of engaging in very serious questions on
which a great deal of
human well-being rests is preposterous
these these
platforms are in no position to evaluate
what you're saying
and that means we have to be able to
discuss it
uh in public well that is what i'm
calling for since many many weeks
because the the
the way the discussion is conducted
right now
is that uh well some fact checkers
reach out to some experts and then you
have some one-liners
in their report some one-liners that so
to say contradict what i'm saying
and then the fact-checker confronts me
with this kind of uh you know
contradictory statements so to say
that is not a discussion and that is and
i i'm asking
all the time you know for these experts
to
to to to start a debate right uh like we
are like we are discussing
then things can be clarified and uh you
know arguments can
and and we could i would love to see a
consensus on
what are the what is going to be the
the criteria that we all agree upon
to say whether or not human intervention
is driving
this this is driving immune escape right
because if there is really
immune escape driven by human
intervention in the way we have been
discussing
then i think everyone will agree that
this is not a good thing this is really
very
problematic but if we don't have
criteria and if we don't agree upon
i mean the only thing will be vaccinate
everybody
right till not everybody is
unless everybody's vaccinated it's not
over right and and
that cannot be according to my
interpretation
no and the pressure to vaccinate
everybody is incredible
the number of uh young people that i
hear are being vaccinated is
preposterous in light of the fact that
there's really
almost no reason to do it um even even
if the
vaccine is as safe and good as it's
being portrayed
it uh the fact is young people
are already immune and there's no reason
to inter intervene in the
well the only caveat that is
this was certainly the case when the
wild strain came in
and and i told my kids you know uh okay
if you have if if you're obliged to
because
you know you have to wear a mask in the
store for example you have to do this
but don't do it
when you are with friends etc and they
are not
they were not participating in mass
gathering gatherings anyway
but now the problem now is with this
highly infectious variance
the likelihood is increasing that
well this is something we didn't discuss
but it's important to understand
when you are an asymptomatic
uh asymptomatically infected so you got
infected
with the virus without developing
symptoms
during a short period in time you will
be developing antibodies
right these are antibodies that are not
very mature
and i'm not saying in all
asymptomatically infected people but in
a fair extent a fair number of
asymptomatically infected people
they will develop antibodies that are
not fully mature and that are
short-lived
so as we as we discussed these
antibodies
will be able to bind to this protein
not neutralize it but out complete
your innate immune response so now with
the highly infectious variant
circulating the likelihood
that as a young guy or lady you get a
hit
by the virus during the time where you
are sitting on your
immature antibodies becomes increasingly
higher right
and that is how we now also see how
younger age groups without underlying
diseases people in perfect health
get severe covet right so you see these
are
criteria for me that are really
important to analyze and to further
discuss and to agree upon
if that is not done and the only
criterion is
we go until everybody gets vaccinated
young or old no matter what
no matter what you know whether they are
in good health or or whatever whether
they are serum positive or seronegative
i mean then it's it's yeah it's it's
really a war situation
right yeah well that's that's very
frightening
all right well this has been a
fascinating discussion um
i look forward to hearing how this
develops and i do hope that people
i i know people are taking your argument
seriously
privately i think there's a lack of
courage in
especially in and around academia where
people won't necessarily say what they
understand because they're afraid of
consequences and in this case
the consequences for humanity are so
immense that i think
uh it is incumbent on people to um
to at least point out that this is an
argument that needs to be taken very
seriously well there
are top experts much more famous than i
am
who i know and who write me that you
know
i'm right but if you're
really a top expert of course you are
working in some of these communities
that are now
or you know deeply involved in in
driving these vaccination campaigns
so unfortunately these people cannot
speak up and i i think it's
it's really given what is at stake
it is yeah i for me it's a moral
obligation uh you know i could be
employed i could be
whatever you know i mean this is so
frightening
to me i i have spent uh
weeks and weeks and nights to understand
what is going on
and uh so
you know having done my homework the
moral obligation
to react is such that you know that this
is for me the absolute prior
priority no matter what well
uh i agree with you about the moral
obligation of it
um it's of course not entirely safe for
me to put you on my channel either i
feel that same moral obligation and i
would just point out
that i think we've lost track
of how much risk people have taken
through
history when something was important and
to the extent that people may have fears
about what happens
career-wise to them if they speak an
important truth they need to recognize
that lives are on the line
this is an argument that must be engaged
and
it's time for them to step up and i
would say to the extent that there are
people who privately acknowledge that
what you're saying
is sensible people who believe you are
right and are in a position to change
uh public opinion i open this channel to
them if they'd like to come on and
and tell us uh what you've got right
what you've got wrong
what they think we ought to understand
i'm more than happy to to host that
discussion
well i i much appreciate that uh brett i
really do
and uh yeah i'm also very much hoping
for uh people ultimately uh because it's
really uh
it's really more than time to do so
because
as you as you will realize right now
things start to
be very fast to evolve very very fast
if you see in some countries because
that is the only the other thing every
country is looking
at its own situation when i hear the
news for example in belgium it's like
the only country where uh where we have
uh a coffee from them right and and the
world is closing in on us
and it's like i mean if there is a
double mutant in
in india that it's resistant for example
that is also my problem that is your
problem that is everyone's problem
and it's like oh let's let's uh let's
put the figures down let's try to to put
a figure down in in
in belgium or in germany or in the uk
right if
if there was ever a situation in which
we should put politics aside
put national boundaries aside and team
up
to address a problem this is it yeah
pandemic is per definition a global
thing
and our strategy is not global at all
right
uh yeah well you know we
we could go on forever at this but uh i
much appreciate uh
you doing this and uh at least giving me
an opportunity to talk about this and
frankly speaking i think
brett we have been very scientific about
this right i mean
yep yeah so um yeah
i think we have we have to um to
continue
to have this discussion and i must say i
greatly appreciate
your courage and your insight i think uh
you're a force for good and i
uh i am so glad that you chose to come
on darkhorse
yeah thank you so much for having me all
right thank you
okay be well everyone
you